auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge in der letzten folge von auf
und davon feierte josef anreiter mit den
kindern in kanada halloween
denn wie immer zur weihnachtszeit
verkauft der beatrice in der schweiz
ihrer eines kurzen an der nordsee
übernahm das ehepaar kunz einen 25 jahre
alten imbisswagen ohne einen einzigen
freien tag stehen sie während wochen
hinter der theke
auch die oma und die kinder helfen mit
die emmentaler erfüllen sich in uruguay
einen lang ersehnten wunsch
seit monaten schon leben zu sein und
rudi althaus auf ihrer baustelle die
enge des containers bereitete vor allem
so seien zusehends mühe
[Musik]
der sommer ist angebrochen und mit ihm
ist auch gekommen
der reinrassige uruguayische simon hat
schon eine freundin die zugelaufene
hunde dame mini eine straßen mischung
[Musik]
der clan der schweizer wird immer größer
der mit ausgewanderte kater curry ist
wie schon in der alten heimat ein
eigenwilliger einzelgänger
das mache ich wenig sagen
und zwar sie nach wien
das erste gästehaus ihrer prosa da alles
selber gebaut ist bald bezugsbereit
bis das ehepaar ein eigenes häuschen hat
werden sie dieses bewohnen gemacht
seit tagen isoliert die 53-jährige den
bungalow doppelwandig vier weitere
gästehäuser und ein restaurant sind
geplant ja ja das machen rafa das
eintönige arbeit hin oder her
jeder tag in der pampa von uruguay
bringt neues und ungewöhnliches
das heutige ereignis ist flavia der
swimmingpool extra aus montevideo
angereist ist pulheim nach ávila bereits
angelegt haben die emmentaler einen
teich für ihre tiere
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite der weltkugel
peitschen heftige herbststürme über die
nordsee
die alljährlichen sturmtiefs zehnter
[Musik]
doch ob wind regen oder sonnenschein
sascha kunz hat hier seinen schönsten
arbeitsplatz gefunden
und die baselbieter haben gut
gewirtschaftet
seit den imbisswagen ins winterquartier
zu bringen
für die kunst ist es das erste mal
[Musik]
nachbar und rehwild die bleus auf
punkten
gut möglich dass die reifen nicht mehr
fahrtauglich sind
[Musik]
dass mitglieder sind
wird es überhaupt noch sehen dass das
passiert noch einmal zurück fahren und
stellplatz und osten hin wechseln hilft
den schweizern aus der patsche
glücklicherweise hat er zuhause ersatz
sowie so unterstützt er die familie wann
immer er kann
35 ja
zum glück hat die binde und dass ich
absolut goldwert ja wirklich nichts
bringt die beiden aus der ruhe
vor allem sascha erscheint an der rauen
see seine berufung gefunden zu haben
[Musik]
auch im kanadischen täter makatsch ist
die saison zu ende
das hotel beherbergt nur noch ein paar
dauergäste ein flügel des velmore hotels
ist während des winters sogar ganz
geschlossen
josef ist zufrieden die an meyers hatten
eine gute erste saison aber geschaltet
und entspricht so ungefähr dem was ich
mir vorgestellt worden von formosa
andere bedauern ich eigentlich zu dieser
späten jahreszeit ist ein neuer gast
eine seltenheit
der ist am 3
ich möchte nur insgeheim
die schule ist aus die kinder sind
aufgeregt denn heute kommt die mama ein
sofia und robin wollen sie überraschen
während der hochsaison hatte die familie
kaum zeit für die eigentlich geplanten
renovationsarbeiten die im sommer
angelieferten möbel blieben in ihren
kartons jetzt aber sind fast alle
kommoden tische und garderoben ausgebaut
wochenlang hat papa josef den betrieb
und den familienalltag alleine gemanagt
beatrix weiter schweiz heute abend kommt
seine frau seine große liebe endlich
zurück
stampfen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einmal mehr unterstützt die schweizer
diesmal mit seinem traktor der küsten
imbiss geht heute in seine wohlverdiente
winterpause
[Applaus]
wie komisch komisch info
komisch ich hoffe es geht alles gut und
gerne mit dem auto auf die drahtseile
musik für orchester brauchen wir jetzt
für ohhh vertrag zwar so dass man kann
ich als kind immer und alles gehört
[Musik]
im schritttempo geht die fahrt nach
platin büttel
[Musik]
wir fühlen uns sehr wohl
jetzt musste er in bis nur noch heil
ankommen
[Applaus]
stolberg
tel aviv
[Gelächter]
erreichen wir mit gott
doch probleme sind oft nicht dort wo man
sie vermutet
der tritt
auf diesem hof wird der grillwagen bis
mitte märz seinen winterschlaf halten
und auch die jungunternehmer glauben
eine winterpause vor sich zu haben
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
in uruguay ist die reisesaison
angebrochen jetzt im dezember besuchen
viele touristen die hafenstadt colonia
del sacramento
sie gilt als eine der schönsten städte
südamerikas
in knapp zwei stunden erreicht man mit
der fähre buenos aires
bei klarem wetter kann man sogar die
skyline der argentinischen hauptstadt
sehen wenige kilometer vom städtchen
entfernt bauen unsere schweizer
auswanderer ihre pusan
[Gelächter]
trotz sommerlicher temperaturen ein
bisschen weihnachtsstimmung muss sein
bei nacht
im frachtcontainer türmt sich der
emmentaler haushalt susan will auch in
uruguay die bräuche die sie in der
schweiz liebgewonnen hat fliegen
sie brauche ich komme ja so ist sehr
schön ich dort unten wartet zu sams
neuesten es soll so richtig heimelig
werden
da bleiben sicherte helm aber bekam mit
dass die behörde hatte aber dann ist
dabei der vater bist ratcliffe rennen
eingeschaltet ist nicht so einfach
daraus konstanter ist gerade eine neue
ware angebot seit monaten leben die
beiden auf kleinstem raum hessische
große etappe dass man jetzt endlich
daher haben wir uns für die tat das
seine aussagen von problemen containern
untergebracht wo es objektiv ist und da
gibt es heute auch im kontext eu ja
richtig gleichzeitig jedoch die metro
stars das mikro zur stelle probleme mit
damit den platz so dass sich ein
webbrowser ein raucher draußen muss ich
mir doch kommt also nicht nötig ist
neben nachvollziehbar
ich begriff dass die luft jagen endlich
mal nicht lief
das hilft mir was ich lieber etwas kann
ich danach folgt sie es ist der 18
das grundstoff bauchspeck dürftig
[Musik]
noch wenige minuten und beatriz ist da
für josef vielleicht die längsten
minuten seines lebens seit 23 jahren war
er nie mehr als drei tage von seiner
liebsten getrennt
einfach mit dem polen schon vorbereitet
ich weiß nicht so recht wo sich ihre
chance bot
ich hoffe dass sie mal braucht hatte das
ist fußball
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
so nicht möglich uns freude
ich habe den zug von einander und das
ist wirklich schön
[Musik]
es heißt das wetter an der nordsee kenne
wieder ruhe noch regeln tatsächlich
bietet die nordsee tag für tag ein neues
naturschauspiel
[Musik]
seit mitte juli ohne einen einzigen
freien tag hat das ehepaar kunst würste
kreiert pommes frittiert getränke
verkauft obwohl die beiden neulinge in
diesem gewerbe sind scheinen sie
umsichtig gewirtschaftet zu haben
ja da haben wir uns gefragt ob sie bei
mir immer sicher 25
denn wenn man sich ab schrieb das ist
gab es auch ist einziger worden ist
irgendwann einfach vorfahrtsfehler
greift dann aber zwei haben geprüft und
zweimal zückt also die letzte aufgabe
warcraft dem volks-nein eine haben uns
wirklich gar nichts
ja also mehr hin zum zum teil wirklich
70 70 kilo pommes frites zu helfen zum
teil ein buch kann ich mich hier 100
currywurst sehe dass ich meinen sohn ins
meer kommt es immer super halb ist dafür
ja wohl keine lehrer und glauben wir
sind auf dem richtigen weg und machen
alles richtig gemacht und wird jetzt
daraus eine messe eigentlich den ersten
sommer haben sie erfolgreich gemeistert
nun kommt ihr erster winter
und noch heute
[Musik]
dank zollte richtung
unglaublich speech in der kammer china
und wegen der weniger kran oder zwei
pfund jährlich 30.000 liter fasst flavia
der gäste pool damit sich die wanne gut
setzen kann muss innert kurzer zeit
möglichst viel wasser in den pool
fließen
es kommt von rudis quelle der emmentaler
checkt die wasserpumpen oder wenig nach
seinem crash
[Musik]
am tag nach beatrice ankunft nimmt bei
den allemal das alles wieder seinen
gewohnten lauf
die kinder gehen zur schule die eltern
arbeiten bevor sie ins hotel fahren
holen beatrice und josef brennholz aus
ihrem eigenen wald
die zürcher sind besitzer von knapp 100
fußballfeldern kanadischen bodens drei
viertel davon ist wald
durchaus mies ins land bis da das ist
lang der visite eines fluges oder und
dienstagfrüh gedroht
da der elektromeister sichere und mir
kommt das natürlich eu klage wurde jetzt
der schock feld spricht auch jenes
gemacht nach denen und
peter busch ist im sommer ausgangspunkt
für touren in die weite natur
im winter jedoch ist es ruhig im 800
seelen ort
josef nimmt beatrice mit auf
überraschungs tour
ok
[Gelächter]
nächster halt ein gästezimmer
das thema ist nicht nur frisch
gestrichen
das hat auch noch eine trennung bekommen
nein so viel geschafft lacht ja ich
mache das nicht zu wählen
die arbeiter sind ein perfektes team
auch beatrice hat in der schweiz viel
gearbeitet und mit dem verkauf ihrer
selbst gebackenen alice kingsley gutes
geld verdient geld das sie investieren
wollen
ich glaube ich lebe das wieder machen
aber ein ich nicht wie lange er im juni
des hauses geschnitzt und laufen sondern
will es einfach es geschafft ich es
geschafft und und mein name hinter und
es kurz geschafft und will alles
kritisch ist ja relativ gering und es
ist ein vielleicht ja
ja
unter dem holz ist sehr gesund
der standplatz des küsten imbiss ist
leer
nach monatelangem durcharbeiten endlich
zeit für die familie
die kunst machen eine wattwanderung der
ist nie gesagt ist 30 zentimeter tiefe
und das ich kriege ich denn eigentlich
nur wieder oben oder nach unten ist der
waschbär hat keine augen keine nase und
keinen und hier das ist ein schwarzer
[Musik]
peter entdecken sie die verborgenen
schätze des nationalparks
zwischen der stolz auf die schweiz
das ist klar ja es ist weg es ist immer
noch erwischt es ist noch nicht so wurde
ich finde das immer noch aus so
faszinierend
es blieb noch nicht es ist ebbe
bevor die flut schnell und lautlos
wieder kommt kann man auf dem
meeresboden der nordsee spazieren ein
einzigartiger lebensraum wird durch die
ebene freigelegt
natürlich nicht so viel jetzt gedanken
durch ein schweizer und der schweiz und
auch tochter noemi hat sich gut in der
neuen heimat eingelebt wie auch hier
zwillingsbruder timo noch um
vorbereitung für erwartet und so weiter
von wegen pause
die frische nordseeluft inspiriert
sascha hat eine neue geschäftsidee
[Musik]
rudi ist ein mann mit großen
gestaltungswillen
er ist gleichzeitig kürzer und planer
monatelang hat er mit einem arbeiter
gräben gezogen eigenhändig wasser und
elektroleitungen gelegt
[Musik]
langsam nimmt die pousada ihr
ferienparadies aus sichtbar form an
[Musik]
bald schon wollen die schweizer mit dem
bau des restaurants beginnen
in einem jahr soll schließlich eröffnung
sein
daher ist im moment noch als geister 10
mit nutzt das ist vielleicht die letzte
chance das ist wie lange und mit jedem
etappenziel wird die freude immer größer
auch in kanada gehen arbeit und freude
hand in hand
[Musik]
die alm haiders besuchen ein
weihnachtsfest
[Musik]
der jung bowling club eingeladen
die arbeiter kinder sind seit drei
monaten im team des außen lane hughes
bowling klappt es gibt ein sogenanntes
pott werk die namen
jeder bringt etwas zu essen mit alles
wird gezeigt
[Applaus]
noch kein jahr ist es her dass die
albers ausgewandert sind
trotz heftigem abschiedsschmerz die
kinder sind auf dem besten weg kanadier
zu werden
[Musik]
so wünschen wir sind immerhin
von wegen winterpause sascha will eine
neue idee umsetzen
mit dem programm
es gibt ein bisschen sascha möchte sich
einen zweiten kleineren imbiss wagen
anschaffen mit diesem wäre er wirklich
mobil
so könnte er auch im winter auf märkten
und bei gutem wetter sogar auf der
platte würste und pommes verkaufen
[Musik]
stephan dietsche und ich bin noch
wirklich so gut machen wie zwei hände
und diesen auf haben sie uns
das ist ein ziel von mehr und die welt
aus und das ist ja auch das spaß macht
das spaß
die drei männer kommen wir jetzt am
gleichzeitig es so viele kennen erklärt
und und das ist wirklich ein anderes das
ist wirklich ein anderer schaffte du
bist immer nimmt einem den straßen wurde
muss für haben trägerschaft der umsatz
von 10 uhr bis zum gehtnichtmehr
und das ist eigentlich so wie groß ist
der stolz aber ein anderes umsatz das
ist für uns christen würden erfüllt
jetzt einen kleinen küsten imbiss
imperium steht also nichts mehr im weg
und dann schicke ich dann ja ja ja ja
super danke sind
[Musik]
für susann und ruhe die ist es nur ein
kurzer fußmarsch bis zum rio de la plata
dieser ist eigentlich der
mündungstrichter zweier großer ströme
brasiliens des ice und s-bahnen weit und
groß wie das meer aber noch süßwasser
der rio de la plata ist ein beliebtes
ausflugsziel
es ist erst wenige monate her dass die
beiden aufbrachen
sie haben sich gegen die gemütlichkeit
des emmentals entschieden und auf ein
schönes abenteuer eingelassen
seit 30 jahren sind sie ein paar
sie hatten ein haus gebaut und drei
kinder großgezogen
mit über 50 wollten sie sich nochmals
neu erfinden nur sie beide ganz allein
wie einst als junges paar cents mehr
oder weniger lang aber was aber durchaus
hauptstadt das haben wir ja aber das
frappierende amtlicher freute dass die
tat mit dem kontrabass ikrk hat und
morgen ulla klopp und smart großer
kapazität der wie die agentur am ganze
projekt kann sagt hey es ist und dass
ich mit probieren sie zu erschaffen
ich glaube dass
schweißt zusammen
[Musik]
wichtiger
träumen
die wilmersdorfer
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge